well we now know that Republicans have
won the house in the 2022 midterms and
will control the House of
Representatives for a two-year period it
will be Hunter Biden 24 7. it may be Joe
Biden impeachment how do we know well
I'll show you in a moment if you needed
any more sense of what to expect though
you need look only over to the Senate
and what 37 Republican Senators there
did in voting against recognizing
codifying same-sex and interracial
marriages it's 2022. it's not 2002 or
1992 or 1922 but 37 Republican Senators
said let's not codify federal
recognition of same-sex and interracial
marriage and that tells us a lot about
what we can expect in the house now one
important thing to mention at the end of
the day
we had shifting forecasts uh polls being
molded like putty we didn't know well as
which scenario the most likely scenario
going into the midterms was Democrats
hold the Senate but lose the house and
that's exactly what happened now of
course it was a circuitous path to get
there but the final result
in the 30 000 foot view is exactly what
we expected now in terms of the Biden
impeachment
Hunter Biden investigations these are
really not maybes first and foremost Jim
Jordan will become chair of the house
Judiciary Committee when this new
Congress is sworn in a disgrace a
humiliation but a very clear sign of
what is to come because we know all
about Jim Jordan's interests in
irrelevant stories like Hunter Biden
secondly we are going to see people like
Marjorie Taylor green now spend two
years trying to impeach Biden probably
three or four times a week and the Hope
has to be that the American people
overall and you know when there are so
many people who have been successfully
targeted by weaponized propaganda that
they will believe that impeaching Biden
and investigating Hunter Biden make
sense as judicial prior legislative
priorities House of Representatives
priorities but the Hope has to be that
most people realize investigating Hunter
Biden does nothing for me about
inflation or wages or health care or
whatever the case may be
um many of us saw this coming there's no
question about it but it is now
abundantly clear that it is going to be
Hunter Biden 24 7. just as a couple of
examples for you
over on Twitter the House GOP Twitter
account has spent much of the last 24
hours uh tweeting about Hunter Biden and
as you scroll down and look at the
things here Joe Biden is the big guy
they tweeted big guy is a reference to a
hunter Biden story in which they say Joe
Biden is referred to as the big guy
who's getting a cut of something you
know these conspiracy theories that they
have they then posted a clip of an
interview with Hunter Biden again
they're obsessed with Hunter Biden then
before that this is all in the last hour
by the way as I'm filming then they
posted a link to a Fox News article
about Hunter Biden then they posted a
picture of Joe Biden allegedly meeting
Hunter Biden's Kazakh business associate
then previously they had posted another
clip from an interview with Hunter Biden
and more pictures of the Biden family I
I'm not going to waste the entire
segment talking about this but going on
and on and on and then by the way this
morning a Fox News covered a press
conference in which Republican
Congressman James Comer
declared that the hunter Biden uh that
Hunter Biden himself is going to be at
the center of Investigations to be
carried out by the Republican house so
there's two ways to look at this one
these people are obsessed
with uh Joe and Hunter Biden in a way
that makes no sense Hunter Biden's not
an elected official he's not running for
anything he has nothing to do with the
administration contrary to Ivanka and
Jared who did have things to do with the
Trump Administration the people are
going to see through it and they're not
going to go for it the Counterpoint
would be hey Republicans have a solution
to just about every problem inflation
well we're going to subpoena Hunter
Biden gas prices are too high subpoena
Hunter Biden what do we do about housing
or China or health care or immigration
or whatever police we're investigating
Hunter Biden and maybe we're even
impeaching Joe Biden will much of the
country fall for it
I don't know I don't know now if we want
to put
the best possible spin on this and by
this I mean Republicans taking the house
making it clear they're going to spend
two years mostly focused on Hunter Biden
this is going to be
the slimmest of slim majorities for
republicans in the house and you could
make the case that this will expose
their
BS their obsession with the relevant
things like Hunter Biden such that in
2024
it will be very helpful to Democrats in
taking back a sizable majority
that's the the sort of rose-colored
glasses view on this they'll have just
enough power to look bad but hopefully
not enough power to cause major
destruction I don't know it's really a
predictive question and as I've told you
before humans are pretty bad at making
predictions the upshot of the obsession
with the hunter Biden stuff is yeah Fox
News is going to talk about it all the
time but I don't think the American
people generally speaking are obsessed
with Hunter at all it's a sliver of the
right that cares about Hunter and so
we'll see where it all shakes out you've
heard me talk about the accounts we've
had hacked it's a horrible experience it
can happen to anyone look up the stats
if it hasn't happened to you yet it may
at some point protecting yourself
against scammers online can get
complicated our sponsor Aura is the
all-in-one solution that I now use to
keep accounts safe Aura scans the dark
web for your personal info emails
passwords Social Security numbers
immediately alerts you if anything is
found helps you fix the problem you also
get alerts about suspicious credit
inquiries or automatically requests the
removal of your information from search
engines and data broker sites and Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware with its state-of-the-art
antivirus and Aura also helps you manage
what your kids can do on their devices
with very simple easy to use parental
device controls you can try or a free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman your
login credentials might already be
floating around it takes only a few
seconds on Aura to figure that out and
think of all of the other useful things
you'll discover during the two-week
trial the link is down below